sir oh no is he mad I can't see anything
did he storm out no I stormed in to tell
you it was a great play and nice work
Peralta and there it is
hey Sarge sorry about the mess hi Cagney
hi Lacey hey your kids like the same
kind of cereal as me well we've just
finished story time I'm Gonna Kiss the
Girls night night and then we can get
down to business
Time for night night girls he is so
strong but so gentle it's like an
enormous muscular Ellen DeGeneres you
know I just wanted you guys know that I
love you girls so so much okay so sleep
tight
you know Daddy will never leave you
right girls rock goodbye gosh really
makes you understand what he went
through
I'm worried about Terry
we can't let anything bad happen to him
Jake where are you
in here
oh this is a classy teepee should we get
these instead of desks at work we have
to get Terry off this case what why look
I thought he was a weirdo for having his
year-long freak out but I get it now he
has children what happens to them if he
gets hurt I'll have to take care of them
or his wife or other family or his more
mature friends but interesting point why
is this just hitting you now I don't
know I guess I just hadn't seen his kids
in so long he never takes him around the
precinct for some reason
of all the guns in danger so again your
Alibi is a mysterious stranger handed
you the gun made you put your prince on
it robbed the store and then hid the gun
in your underpants Well yeah if you say
it like that it don't sound believable
oh hey Captain did you get my report on
the Finley murder oh yeah looked it over
nice work good thanks Dad
why is everyone staring at me you just
called Captain hold dad he said thanks
Dad what no I didn't I said thanks man
do you see me as a father figure Peralta
no if anything I see you is a bother
figure because you're always bothering
me hey show your father some respect I
didn't call him Dad no no no no Jacob I
take it as a compliment it's not a big
deal I called Vivian mom once and she's
my fiance guys jump on that Boyle has
psychosexual issues old news but you
calling hope Daddy Daddy is not on the
table here but you did call him dead
dude you shut up you've done nothing but
lie since you got here all right all
right I was lying about the holdup but
the dad thing that happened
he admitted that his Alibi was a lie it
was a trap all part of my crazy devious
plan I believe you thank you son
you want to talk about it later over a
game of catch
I'd like that hey you Melvin I am who
are you I'm Charles from being on hold
and I want my package yeah I already
told you that package isn't here I made
a sacred promise to my son and you're
not gonna make a liar out of me so why
don't you take another look we'll wait
because we've got
all night long
damn oh I don't know if you knew this
but I'm a cop so maybe this time don't
lie to me hey I didn't know you guys
were police well now you do genius
there's a lot being gang okay the gal
apoo they smuggle guns and containers
that come from Latvia sometimes there's
other packages that get lost in the
process okay if you want to find yours
you got to find them gun running
gangsters huh well looks like we're
gonna take down the Latvia mob hell yeah
we are
bleeding Charles is bleeding uh
Charles fill me in and he breaks in the
case
I understand
the handyman has an alibi but I found
something else so great thank you the
lab Tech's analyzed Francis phone call
there were two other voices in the
background
wait is that Scully feeding Mac was
Franzia inside the building no his voice
is playing over a speaker in the
background Franzia must have bugged the
precinct and he was listening to it when
we called him
yeah
but why would he bug scully's nap closet
because he didn't bug the closet
she bugged something broad inside oh my
God Franzia was the weird babysitter he
gave the bug right to you
son of a but right as we get there
and Franzia disappears into these crazy
underground tunnels so we have to switch
over to night vision and Charles it's
all so awesome but I actually have to
stop you because I gotta go I have to
feed this baby some mushed up avocado oh
my God what happened is Mac okay
he just pulled himself up
[Music]
I can't believe they call this a silent
Disco This is not a disco and I should
know I was raised on Disco
[Music]
little terry loved the hustle
excuse me can I get a bottle of water
good move giggle dehydrates the hell out
of you yeah I don't do that stuff I
don't even drink hey you should my
daughters go to the learning Grove you
get that from a vintage store or
something no I went there I was in the
Dolphins class and you don't do drugs or
drink have a water on the house
well she was useless not entirely I
learned that my babies are on the right
track because their preschool turns out
nice kids yeah I can't wait to hold that
at the task force meeting
now let's go look for some bad kids who
went to sub power preschools hey so
what's your plan with gintars he's kind
of taken over the whole waiting area oh
don't worry about me I'm watching mad
about you and Latvian Hulu that's a very
funny show very many episodes I could
sit here all day
I don't know what to do he's never gonna
leave but I'm scared for Nicolas to get
to know him okay how about this guitars
just wants to see him right we can maybe
have them meet without telling nikolaj
the guitars is his birth father just say
he's an old friend of ours Jake you're
completely forgetting about the
olfactory Bond nikolaj will immediately
recognize his father's scent well you
got to do something and I don't think
you're gonna wait this guy out oh no
Paul and Jamie are locked in the
bathroom but Jamie has a turkey in the
oven
this is a very good setup
so good okay Jake let's give your plant
a shot
okay again turns remember the deal is
you cannot tell nikolaj you're his
father again tux I'm Billy Hanukkah I'm
from the Bronx Manhattan I eat pizza at
uh famous race okay well no need to get
too specific or offer up any backstory
hey guys I'm just coming from work with
my friend Billy Hanukkah Hanukkah it's
fine kids don't know which names are
weird Nikolai say hi to Jake and this
stranger hi Jake I love you nice to meet
you Mr Hanukkah I love you too man he
really is a boil isn't he
so
you're leaving
it must have been a hard decision
honestly
it wasn't it's funny on my first day
here I asked Jeffers to tell me about
everyone told me you were a great
detective but the one thing you couldn't
figure out was how to grow up
well
I think you finally figured it out
well thank you sir I couldn't have done
it without you over the years you've
sometimes referred to me as something of
a father figure did I I didn't realize
that but I want you to know if I had had
a son
and uh it turned out like you
I would be very proud of them
thank you sir
wow
I wasn't expecting to get this emotional
it's not bad for an old robot huh
Warp asleep
sir did you just make a joke I believe I
did yes I guess in the end we rubbed off
on each other quite a bit
tired of your sex movie
did I do it right
it was perfect
all right